天啊 今天台積鏈居然暫停
台積鏈已經0050暫停
台股這一波
暫真的嗎
我知道今天應該幾十萬觀眾朋友在看我節目
啊 我好興奮喔
第二個
我買1億的0050
昨天叫你踏著我的雪前進
怎麼辦
我0050
今天一天
就大賺1000萬了
因為暫停版了買1億啊
全世界都知道我買1億啊
我何時要出
第三個
韓國股市大漲18%
台灣股市
還有的漲嗎
外面給我
今天獨家的預告
在此之前
我們先來喝一杯
好不好
慶祝一下
小安
來來來
哎呀
我們喝一下
欸 投資長
是
我知道這個梗
是要幫空軍祈禱對不對
不是
今天不是幫空軍祈禱
今天是幫空手的人祈禱
很難熬啊
我就說你庫端裡面還有錢
我就說你租公租宰要宰出來
要宰
你們就不理我
今天來不及
是不是 館長來不及了
這只是說預告在前面
空手的人現在最可憐
做空等人不會覺得現在很可憐
還有現金人最可憐
喝一杯
喝茶乾杯
我不太能喝酒
好啦 謝謝大家
來 畫面給你
今天台灣股市真的很精彩
今天台股狂拉3186点
最后收涨在43119点
真的太疯狂了
台股史上最大涨点就是今天
而0050竟然涨停了
台积电也涨停
这就发生在投资涨砸一亿新台币
买进0050之后
简直不可思议
真的太神了
很多投资朋友觉得投资涨喊今年5万
只是在说笑
结果今天一眨眼
怎么就突然突破4万3了
怎么离5万越来越近了
而且今天投资长一大堆股票
都走高喷上涨停
投资长的好戏登场精彩
这档股票和群联
都是一开盘就涨停
还有昨天跌停的国具
投资长早就叫你要买
甚至还说
只有国具的00981A
也可以考虑买进
结果今天通通都喷上涨停了
你想買都買不到
全台灣到底有誰能公開大買0050
還省準抓到轉折點
你手上還沒有標股嗎
你是不是後悔沒有OIN
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
大家好
我今天本來要賭神配樂出產了
太累了
好不好
我要告訴大家啦
元大台灣50
真的是
我看剛剛送我一個匾額
惠我娘多
要寫清楚不是罵髒話
不是罵我家人
惠我娘多
欸 暫停板耶
昨天跌停的時候
請問大家
誰敢像我這樣用力買
你昨天有時間
我是前天買的喔
是
我是前一天我就預告
前來我就花
我是以前的陳清風的信徒你知道嗎
棒球球來就打
錢來我就花
送給我就花
我真的覺得你們
男生女生很奇怪
百貨公司周年慶
帶家人去Shopping
哇
Shonel 95折
排隊排隊
卡厲害排隊排隊
打來打去這92折
台灣股市一堆打對折你不要
你不要
太可惜了各位
你告訴我全台灣誰有這麼尷尺
你看 你這看
我昨天表都不見了
今天表又出來了你知道嗎
又出現了
輸回來了嗎 賺夠了
輸回來了
一天一千萬怎麼不夠輸
輸回來了是開玩笑的
這這種表都在啦好不好
只是昨天與民同在
與大家跟大家同在啦
與散戶同在
你告訴我台積電
比哲哲有錢的人也是很多啦
一億啊 還是很多人比我錢
可是誰敢承受這壓力
還有人說 喔
哲哲
你這個錢哪來的
什麼哪來的 我辛苦賺了
投資票 你們根本不了解我
我這件事 底下留言
我是不是連續三年在台灣股市崩盤六七千點的時候
我都買在相對地點
連續三年 沒有下來一居高
差不多翻盤到差不多六千點的時候
都這樣子耶
這次也很厲害啊
你告訴我就在這天啊
我還告訴你老天爺要送錢給我花
四萬點在哪邊
在這邊
這四萬點沒錯吧
是
四萬點在這邊
欸 等一下有兩天啊你買
我前一天還預告耶
你們底下留言拜託讓他們知道
因為有些是新粉你知道嗎
最近好多新粉絲耶
對
你知道注意好多新的粉絲
男生女生突然愛我
你知道我在脆上面看到我嚇到了
我在滑滑脆 滑滑臉書
有人跟我表白說
哲哲是他的男生
我沒跟你誇張
我很緊張
我真的很緊張
我不知道
你們愛的是我的肉體
還是愛的是我的腦袋
我希望你們愛我的腦袋
還是
愛的是我的金錢
我不知道
不過沒有關係
人生命一條 有愛過就好
我也愛大家
I love you
I stay rude
還有 韓語叫什麼
沙拉黑喔
小韓是韓國人
我愛你
我喜歡你啊 各位
我都喜歡你們
我順便用一下
ChairGPT
你知道我最近都叫他訓練
訓練你知道嗎
我問大家
我都是愛你們
哈囉
等他一下
嗨 來了
來了
你剛剛說
我要跟你說 請問一下
我開始講韓語的
我愛你怎麼講
是
好
那個法語
法語
法文是
je dame
然後
對 然後
西班牙文你要不要
好
西班牙文是 te amo
Te amo
再一次
法文是
法文是 je t'aime
Je t'aime
Te amo
我在跟別人講話
沒錯
Te amo
Je t'aime
I love you
不要插嘴 謝謝
好
我在跟人家表白
謝謝你
I love you
加油
好啦 你加油
I love you
好的
欸 你很吵欸
不要她了
這樣
你看
人家家是不是很容易鬥嘴
我為什麼要有AI跟大家講
我要跟大家講
這就是AI啊
我跟你講
我認為三年內
我跟你講你們是客服人員
你們要記得
你看他現在都跟我鬥嘴
你知道嗎
你可以每天跟他聊一整天
他現在反應越來越快
我剛才來問他
你是不是有改版
他說對
他最近這一週有改版
你說AI
你們看不懂嗎
以後很多人會失業
我是跟你認真的
你最好的保險
不是跟壽險公司買
而是買AI股
看著這個節目
記得看著這個節目
很多人會質疑我
說瓜哥
你買E是真的假的
你們根本不夠了解我
我什麼叫真的假的
我們看一下我們的預告
剛剛預告啊
剛剛很多人講
再寫一次
我什麼連續三年是不是買最低點
是不是
AI太好笑了
這時候愛你
謝謝我也愛你
好不好
AI真的有沒有看到
笑死各講各的
不能往前花
再給他們看一下
再給他看一下
我是不是連續三年
給他們看一下
都買在
去年买在18000
4月11號這邊
附近
反彈2萬2千點
都有新聞報導
前年买在
也是跌6000點
有沒有
2萬4千點
這邊跌6000點
6000點
5000多點
應該算5000點
好
所以我剛剛修正我的話
大跌5、6000點的時候
大概5、6000點的時候
我在這邊
怎麼樣
1萬9000
對 差不多快4,800
大跌4,500以上的時候
我用力買 而且這天也是很漂亮喔
我也是買的時候有沒有看到
跟今天一樣喔
買了以後隔天還在修正一波
是不是跟這次很像
真的喔
而且那次更誇張的是
那次我這邊空手啊
我這次沒有空手到 可惜啊
但是因為我成本很多很低啦
好不好 所以那時候我穿空手道
欸
我是反彈
至少差不多約五六千點的時候
我在最低點進場
連續三年 台灣五十
你們根本不了解我啊
你們根本不了解我
如果我作假 我下台一鞠躬
好不好 我這跟大家講
大家來看一下
明年經濟日報頭版
1萬粉絲要出來
哇666 你看他OK
哲哲出了0050
有沒有考到009816
來 我們看一下9987
這什麼 今天直播的這麼多
我們今天直播的1萬人喔
很多新粉的
很多女生
很多男生
我看他是不是
還有人說他畏畏畏者者啊
幫歪了啦
就是改變性向啊
像小孩一樣
小孩本來喜歡女生看到我都喜歡我
喔 那我可以理解
那可以理解
60秒的時候都脫摸我一下
你們都不知道
每次說 欸 投資長
那個我幫你整理西裝領帶
你們看到我現在都趕快自己整理好
謝謝你
小孩謝謝你的愛
好不好
我告訴大家啦
我為什麼昨天節目那麼激動
我不激動你怎麼記得我啊
各位
我說真的
我講很多名言 很多人叫梗圖啊
你記得我其中一個名言啊
這個不知道是有前面天高講過
創新高你也不敢追
拉回30%你也不敢買
你看退出股市算了
股市跟你有什麼關係
你看這節目很好笑
加碼啊 加油啊
他說加碼加油
還有人懷疑我夢馬一役耶
我還跟大家講 我直接講喔
永夢板星9A9J嘛
是
永夢板星在文化路那邊
旁邊有個加油站啊
我板橋人啊
我跟大家講好不好
我直接講啊
你如果抓到我沒有買台灣50
我給你1億
你再去找永豐金的
因為只有永豐金的營業員跟高層
你可以知道嘛對不對
對
如果他們跟你講說
我沒有買
有證據說我沒有買台灣50
這一次在跌破四萬點的時候
我沒有買台灣50
我這個展示板是假的
有證據
我再給那個營業員
或是券商的高層1億
這樣OK吧
沒有人有必要替我守這個秘密吧
如果我做壞事的話
是
所以這1 ok吧
所以不要再問真假了好不好
幼稚喔
我100多萬粉絲
我做這種東西
我當分析師欸
或許你們可以接受
我不小心闖蠻燈
但你們不能接受
我機下造假
我跟你講我也不能接受啊
所以話說回來了
我國者能在股市中
輕收一天賺1000萬
可是你說我很開心嗎
我不開心
因為我接很多股票暫停
但我對自己要求很變態
譬如說
說美金今天沒給我展情
我很生氣
我說老實話
我很不開心
我告訴大家
你們也不要說
有人說什麼
哎呀投資長
你會有人賠錢
我賺錢
我最討厭聽這句話
第一個
我可以自己偷偷賺
我買台灣50
我不用
我不用跟各位講
沒錯吧
沒錯
為什麼我要講
我是要沉住你的心
我要承接你
我要承接你的不安
我要接納你的心
那你知道在台灣股市跌4萬點的時候
你還是有溫暖的
你知道我錯的時候多丟臉
幸好我每次都錯時間不多
這次不算有錯
你懂嗎
那你有沒有回錯過頭來想連續三年台灣股市崩盤了五六千點的時候我都進產生最低點你覺得我需要一定當分醫師嗎你覺得我一定要當分醫師嗎
不用
不要 那為什麼當分醫師
我真的是來幫助大家
雖然這樣講一定有噁心
至少你一定可以確定一件事情
我不一定要當分醫師 沒錯吧
所以大家珍惜一下我 好不好
如果有網路在 啊有些無聊的批評
還有一些講 頭髮是假的
拜託 頭髮
我昨天還乾剃頭髮 怎麼會是假的
假髮也可以剃 是不是
而且我頭髮最厲害的是
小行好像 我有讓小行摸過是不是
又硬又翹
不要把這個公開的秘密講出來
亂講話 是軟的 可是有翹
很奇怪 我也不知道能撐多久
天生的
到了
白頭髮還沒有幾根
這跟大家講 這頭髮真的
哲哲負貨貸負貧貿大頭啦
哲哲不是負貨貸
你就問大家都知道
很多奇怪的言論
哲哲沒有買台灣物資
有啦好不好
都心粉啦
好不好
愛你們啦好不好
OK
好嗎跟大家講看一下
姚慈基姆展廳
欸我昨天有講啊
我跟妳講
我說我看他們也有看過節目啊
昨天一大堆主動型ETF啦
是不是
昨天一大堆主動型ETF
賣國具
只有郭子龍跟姚慈基姆00981A
用力買國具
我昨天講420幾塊我要買
有
來你們看重播
我說400
450幾吧
你們自己看重播
我真的是對他們很好
來
看重播
我會很激動
看一下
刺激一下
我覺得很多股票是這樣
國具也是
大家國具也殺過頭
傻過頭了 今天又再可以疊停辦
國際有進產啦
不要再說我罵00981A啦 好不好
好不好
我現在跟00981A的那個
姚慈欽姆
我姚慈欽姆之前有的人說我罵他
沒有
我支持你
我跟你講啦
我說甚至你現在可以買00981A
如果你不知道什麼時候要買
什麼要買
我做人很公道啦
我從來不拗人家
你打聽我郭忠為人
我告訴大家
做生意我很公道
我告訴你做生意很公道啦
這就是別人拗我啦
我沒在拗人家的啦
我全部不拔人家錢的啦
整整找不到這種人好不好
所以有沒有看到
姚慈欽補了00981A
今天怎麼樣
等一下電腦都
00981A
你看
今天也暫停啦
不論你是買環球金啊
買國際的啊
買台灣50啊
買台積的啊
偷偷暫停
告訴我
我今天要早點結束
你知道今天大概有8家
是
8家電視台
因為我說老實話
我蠻變態的
他們早上找我我都不理他
因為第一個早上我要看股票
你知道嗎
而且我還很認真看股票
就算有時候在外面我一直在看股票
我很認真看股票
所以我不接受採訪
下午也算了
而且我比較變態是
因為我比較追求那個完美
至少有一點裝啊
裝聾的話
下午受訪
所以我今天要提早結束
我七八家不誇張
大家都會看到
大家電視來訪問我
我是告訴大家啦
有沒有天賦
你看不出來嗎
你以為這是
只有賣天賦的我是不是
賣天賦
OK嗎
看一下我們的簡訊吧
先看一下我們的簡訊
來看一下
你幫我念一下期望
在禮拜四的時候
念一下
好
期望
是
7月30號星期四
早上8點37分
请盘前挂40128点进场波段多单
后续台指期可能会有千点以上的波动
来看一下千点以上波动好不好
这方面是控制风险什么的
居店
因为8点37分就
8点45分之前嘛
8点45分是期货开盘
所以8点37分先挂
所以45分后成交
成交多少念一下
我们期货多单实际成交在开盘价407点
後續台紙期可能會有千點以上的波動
好 千點以上波動 這厲害
我剛才四萬點嘛 四萬零七點
那七點不用算也沒關係啦 好不好
要算可以啦
四萬零七點
今天收多少
今天四萬三千六百七十八點
欸 期握收四萬三千六百七十八點
會員大賺三千六百七十一點
一天而已啦
像保證金多少
保證金挑高
一天而已
賺70幾萬
一口
等100%以上的報酬
只要算一下
大台期貨保證金
恭喜你幫我念一下
期貨期貨
恭喜
我們昨天在407點
進場的波段
多單短短一天
就大賺3671點
一口就大賺73萬
手上多單
獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
好 恭喜大家
還有我們來看一下國劇的
看畫面給我畫面
國劇的
所以我說國劇也供合簡訊啊
有買喔
誰敢買
國劇我叫他展就展
我叫他敵他不敢展
我叫他反彈
馬上反彈給我看
是不是很聽話
你們不要外行看那鬧
內行看門鬧
走 好會表演
我昨天不這樣子專風賣傻一下
喜媽
不然你們昨天都走掉了
前天都走掉了
我很用心良苦耶 你知不知道
小黃唱一下用心良苦好了
我唱一下
你不會唱喔
我們都隨性的
沒關係 不會唱沒關係
看一下國劇
國劇 恭喜股價一開盤
就暫停鎖死
手上持股報報了
我跟你說真的
我今天公司希望我推專案
我沒有很希望
因為參加人太多
那我覺得沒有差
可是今天我推一個反彈99專案
你今天國劇
因為我第一天
我前天跌停就買了
所以你在前天跌停的時候
我跟你講
我跟你講有東西
我算個數學給你看
100元的股票跌停板
變多少
90元嗎
是
90元的股票
一根跌停板再一根展停板
先90元
再展停板是99元
所以一根點停板再一根展停板
其實還沒有回到原本價格
沒有比前天高
所以你現在參加會員
你還很划算
禮拜二禮拜三我就不知道了
反彈99專案你自己參考好不好
禮拜二禮拜三我也不知道好不好
OK嗎
反彈99專案有沒有看到
國劇有沒有看到
大家開心啦
好不好
真的真的我都預告在前面
我跟大家講我都預告在前面
你們再看一下
你們再看一下我這些東西
來看一下
來來
我怎麼說
我在前一天講
你看
728什麼時候
你們看一下
看一下看一下728
這邊這邊是728這邊
再沒有破4萬點的時候
低點那邊我不知道
是
我說可是破4萬點我一定要買
很難去計測嘛
可是老天爺送錢給我花
我知道我就要啦對不對
來 大家看一下喔
很誇張
那時候我就預告囉
再等一下
來 現在破線了嘛
所以你純金屬分析不如天賦分析
比較好 你分析我比較好
可是破4萬點老天爺要送錢給我花
我就砸嘛
很快就可以8萬點了啦
5年內甚至4年內10萬點
等於1億變2億五啊
天啊
那要不要
當然要
要啊 所以
昨天我問你昨天台灣股市抵達3萬9
你們誰有幾位認為郭子宏是值得相信的
會談到5萬點
除了我會員以外
沒幾個相信啊
半信半疑而已
對我們來說聽郭子宏的言論只是隱正直渴
是真是假半信半疑
萌萌萌萌中
且信
且談
且走
就這樣子
你告訴我
誰能這麼厲害
畫龍點睛
含水會結凍
還要像我這樣拋頭落臉
還要被人這樣笑
我真的是希望能幫助大家
昨天沒有幾位相信
今天我要跟你講
現在一下子就43000喔
昨天39000 現在一下43000喔
我們看一下43000幾
沒錯吧
沒錯
起握43000 678
今天一下43000了
昨天沒有人相信4000點
會站穩
昨天沒有人相信
今天會5萬點
今年會5萬點
今天所有人都相信
台灣股市今年5萬點
因為一天3000點啊
大概3000就可以結束啦
是
這就是人性啊
股市每攢1000點
變成智商好像多了10一樣
每跌1000點覺得自己好像傻瓜一樣
從頭到尾你是你 郭仲是郭仇
就這麼簡單
你以後
你有什麼信心不足的
看我們節目就對了
OK嗎
所以從到現在我們來跟大家講
我們來看昨天有個畫面
非常的
非常的嗎
大家非常的很開心
看一下
什麼畫面
就是台南黨區的畫面
很多人喜歡這畫面
來來
台南黨區
我們來喊口
好
這畫面會叫
台股崩盤
台南黨區的畫面
哇
信心不倒 台股不倒
我們昨天喊這畫面說大家好喜歡你知道嗎
團結信心紀律策略盈利
你們幹嘛你們可以先出現
我們先喊一次看看好不好
好
有沒有看到 喊一下
來
團結
全畫面全畫面
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
再一次好了
團結
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
我想到了
不好意思
我們是有準備一個必勝的頭巾
來拿一下給我
頭長 那個勝利沒有了 剩下小心頭巾
蛤 是什麼 小心
不是 我以為是什麼 小心謹慎
好啦 我們拿一下
只有蠟筆小心頭巾
蠟筆小心也可以 好不好
那我們戴一下
單分醫師真的很可憐
我的頭巾我不一定試了 實在是
這樣OK嗎
很好看
好看嗎 我覺得不好看
OK 喊一下
我看這畫面又不行了
誰說我要戴的 你們跟我講
草長其實很可愛
可愛的頭
好啦 喊一下啦
團結 信心 信心 濟慮
濟慮 策略 策略 獲利
我愛各位 謝謝
小韓你被犯了
好
喔
我看我頭髮還是
還是不動 不動如山
我發現我還是穿西裝 戴眼袋比較好
戴這個比較好
喔
這頭型也不行啊
所以你去想想看你要成分審師啦
好不好
我們畫面先不用給莉莉
因為畫面
莉莉頭髮已經亂掉了
沒有開玩笑是真的啦
欸 我們看一下大家
大家對我們這些
喔 我不搞笑你們會
昨天你們早就賣掉了
所以姐姐也是
採衣餘青耶 你知道嗎
你們變成是我醫師父母了
姐姐也不缺錢
但你們變我醫師父母了
採衣餘青了
你們開心啦
有沒有開心
今天我可以臭P一整天
我反正今天溫馨一下 好不好
OK嗎
來 他們看一下
我裝什麼掉 依依
你需要補
不用
不用齁
來
這個要笑死了
依依喔
依依
你整個畫面OK啊
笑翻了
昨天很多人說一起喊
就沒問題了
是不是
台股愛玩團長
我今天畫面很崩欸
你們怎麼樣啊
我今天直播了一萬一耶
崩點來來ETF基金管理人你知道嗎一點喔這幾天ETF基金管理人你會團隊要準時在2點半看折承節目
看完要寫信的報告
真的嗎
他們不看我節目
那些ETF基金的不看我節目
活不下去啊
姚思基姆
我跟你講你們都加油啦
不要說折承丁你們啦
我們可以共好啦好不好
你們賺你們的
我們賺我們的
沒有關係啦
你們壓力很大啦
我知道啦
怎麼沒有壓力大
我自己扛個1億
那個1億自己1億賠錢
賠個1分鐘我都不高興
那個是面子問題
是不是
可是你看今天展題就好開心
看著的節目好開心
看著的
叫你做個必勝投金
來個小新投金
上面有個小新
天剛物造小新火珠
你看我發火小孩
大家有後悔沒買正額嗎
我幹嘛後悔
我又不缺錢
我完全不
我有點見識
對 出掉一些謠傳
我看什麼今日報還是什麼
還是民視還有報導
什麼謠傳
就是說我踩到地雷
我基亞沒踩到地雷
是我基亞出掉以後
我的粉絲踩到地雷
所以我告訴自己以後
要小心謹慎 個股
拜託有新聞記者要拜託更正一下
我郭泽沒有踩到基亞地雷
我地雷沒有地雷
我出得很漂亮
我好像賺幾十%出掉了
賺很多
是有粉絲
我不知道他真的是我粉絲嗎
可是他隔一陣之後來抱怨說
他記啊怎麼辦
好像是看我們節目
可是看我們節目看一看
為什麼不看呢
是這樣子
可是我覺得不管了
所以我任何時候的言論都要謹慎
所以我現在跟你講
這樣政二很不錯
我怎麼知道會不會明年後
政二整個崩盤
腰斬在腰斬
來個金融海嘯
我不知道機率很低啊
但我不要躲那萬分之一啊
所以我不推薦槓桿型的ETF
懂不懂
所以我怎麼會後悔
如果我今天
說老實話我也不會後悔
如果我今天是
不是分析師
我可能自己會買政二
你知道什麼
因為我完全知道我的風險在哪裡
快樂你知道哲哲我就可以買
那不要不要不要
你們
你們不是哲哲
你們有在昨天買1億嗎
沒有就不要買槓桿嘛
好不好
我也覺得沒錯吧
沒錯
等你們像我這樣能力那麼強的時候
再考慮好不好
OK嗎
哲哲一直戴頭照照下播啦
不要啦
你今天很High畫面OK
只有小心
好不好
OK
增額風險
哇
怎麼
今天直播的說也太多了吧
好不好
不論00981還是00991
我不知道我做什麼東西
ETF
他們都很辛苦啦
好不好
這些基因人都很幸福
大家一起把股市做大
好不好
OK嗎
OK
說不定哪天姚慈姬姆
也覺得我環球金不錯
再加碼
這鬧一定
反正我們都選基優股啊
是不是
久人就知道姊姊
我是全台灣
因為有人不認證
去年我股票很慘的時候
其實星星
從3037星
從120跌到780
被好多人罵
還有人成立資就要告我
他們就被那些分析師給慫恿了
慫恿以後是不是要告我
是不是70塊就會走掉
你們都要討厭我
你怎麼會留我的股票
70塊 星星漲到1000塊
我跟大家講
很多人不知道這消息喔
我看我買台灣的資料就知道
我不需要跟主力配合
我全台灣唯一法院證交所證明
那時候在徵器大隊查我所有的進出
我股會員的進出
就是我簡訊買對不對
然後
有沒有這個時間有沒有突然
異常賣
大量的賣
是
對不對
沒有
證交所有證明喔
法院絕不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
還要查到證交所去耶
確骨
114年度他自12233號
直接簽結
去問一下法律人什麼要簽結
比不起訴更
罪證更輕
根本就沒什麼罪證
要兩個檢察官
好像還有其中一個主任檢察官
同意
很容易
折折沒問題
才可以
牽結
比不起訴更難
因為我是清白的
懂嗎
所以你們不要擔心折折不會害大家
先來看一下
天干物詐好不好
台下店怎麼暫停不了
台下店
你們很喜歡必勝投機
我覺得這個很好笑耶
對啊
好不好
捐救護車
我有講啊
A姐你不要有人講
五萬點
不要啦
五萬點折折一下就到五萬點
我很快要捐救護車
我昨天是講6萬點喔
5萬點只能賺大概2500萬
2500萬就要捐5、6百萬
是可以啦
但我想要賺
有6萬點大家要感覺好不好
明年6萬點
我今年擴展就完了
今年12月我桃園市
桃園市吧
消防局的救護車
我要捐
到時候我有個捐的儀式
我再拍照給大家看
好不好 OK嗎
好不好
哲成出來選總統
不要鬧不要鬧
我沒有 我沒有
人紅的事非多
我是分析師
我做好分析就好
好不好
不要搞政治
政治非我專長
我也不想得罪誰
所以藍綠紅白
我通通沒有什麼想得罪的
我做好我的事就好了
好
而且一億難
一天就賺一千萬喔
好不好
而且我很好是
四萬點前一天
跟你講到四萬點
四萬點當天跟你講我買
我買台灣50
四萬點前一天
我說我要買一億台灣50
然後跌破4萬點
跟你講我真的買台灣50
隔天還有一整天的時間
又跌破4萬點
三天讓你準備
三天
事實上不只講三天
因為快跌破4萬點的時候
我就暗示你 跌破4萬點我就買
老天爺要把怎麼樣
錢拿給我花我就花 有沒有講
有
有啊 我剛才有存播過嘛對不對
好像有嗎
好像有沒有
你都累到了沒有
那個 有什麼存播
老天爺要給我錢花
好像有講喔
應該有講喔
沒有嗎
有啦 有啦 有講
你們都忘記了
還有我昨天講這東西
你再看一下
我昨天有一段話很猴
這段話我也喜歡
再給你們重複一下
我讓你們愛我愛多生
你看
等我一下喔
所以今天畫面都秀走秀走
這時候賺了一一
但沒時間去買新的筆電
不好意思
等一下喔
淡掉了啦
那我們先看股票
網路怎麼淡掉了
還有什麼股票我們看一下
紅海勒
紅海就看起來要噴出去啦
紅海今天暫停了
紅海本來就
紅海你看這波為什麼沒跌
拜託15倍本益比不到啊
為什麼台達電
台達電我跟你講還是有機會殺下去
為什麼台達電就是60倍本益比
你想那麼多幹什麼
好不好
但是現在已經砍很多了
其實現在不要砍股票了好不好
現在是換股票
337是精彩
精彩
我跟你講精彩還可以買
因為還有一件事
今天你記得今天我推薦的股票
有展停版的
禮拜一
平盤以下都可以買
等於同一買今天展停版嘛
是
你今天買不到不代表禮拜一買不到
你今天買不到不代表禮拜一展買不到
所以今天你不要再開來看帶頭青
重點是
來來 我只要問大家一件事情
我們現在投票表決
來投票
你們不要騙我
第一個
這我真的沒錢了
好不好
OK嗎
哲哲我還有錢
好不好
庫檔裡面的錢也要算錢喔
除非一千元以下就算了
是
哲哲我還有錢
哲哲我真的沒錢了
我們投票表決
你們不要騙自己
看你們有沒有錢
好不好
是不是這樣突然有錢
我已經叫你買好幾天了喔
投票表決一下
所以我告訴你
今天重點是有些股票暫停版
今天買不到
禮拜一你一定要買
你最平盤就可以了
或是平盤高一點點
等於展停盤不
禮拜一的平盤價
就是今天展停價嘛
所以你還是買得到啊
今天3000多人排隊
不代表禮拜一
還是3000多人排隊喔
是
懂嗎
環球金今天
900多人排隊
不代表禮拜一
還900多人排隊喔
國際有可能啦
因為姚慈金母買嘛
還有姊姊加姚慈金母嘛
對不對
OK嗎
剛才有網友說
很多ETF經紀人
看姊姊的節目寫報告
你不去看我節目很紓壓嗎
而且我都選大型
而且我絕對不會害你
不需要做這種事
去打聽一下
去各個頭顧
尤其摸頭顧打聽哲哲
好不好
是很慷慨的
是不拗人家的
好不好 OK嗎
來
這個站自己講有點噁心
去打聽一下
國劇喔
因為要吃金門
加哲哲的加持
而且他真的談太兇了
男神經病
你們看
今天展廷版還是打
今天展廷版還是打四折
你們聽說什麼
今天展廷版打四折
氣壞喔
這股票先談到800再說吧
先談到800再說
為什麼800再說
你們不要看只會表演而已
來看一下
800來看一下
800日調線對不對
對
800元
這邊全部都是高檔賣
有沒有
爆量有沒有看到
是 沒錯吧
沒錯
這邊看起來才量
才慢慢減少
是今天才爆出量來
800元這邊都爆量
這800元有沒有看到
好 我今天買到500元 我還可以談什麼
還可以賺60%
這60%是輕輕鬆鬆就會漲上去的
很機會 很有機會喔
你要不要賺60%
要
要啦 要啦 是不是
來來來 我們來這邊投票看一下
看你們還有沒有錢
好不好 OK
投票 看比例就知道了
來
你看 你看 你看
一半的人有錢 我氣死我了
等一下等一下 我等一下 不要了
這資料我要看一下
校長太激動了啦
校長一半
等一下 我等一下講什麼我不知道
沒有啦開玩笑 我大概記得啦
我氣死我
我記得很多經典畫面怎麼辦
欸 你們一半人有錢 你們對齊我嗎
我聲淚俱下
跟你們講 從你們褲襠你們拿錢
你們褲襠裡面不能拿錢嗎
不能拿出來嗎
諸公諸宰不能宰一宰嗎
不能宰嗎
這不是諸公
算了
小阿你不用過來
你不是足夠
我不喜歡人身攻擊
你還有錢52%
我起頭
我以為大概三層而已
我還在罵人
我現在是罵不下去啊
又罵又心疼啊
真的沒錢就算了嘛
你還有錢
你們告訴我為什麼人都要這樣子
唉呦
我好激動喔
欸 莉莉有想過還那麼多人還有錢嗎
莉莉有一點太多了
是不是
是
這一點太多對不對
來來來
一戰成神我早就很有名了好不好
我三戰好不好 四戰好不好
O1太重義了 重義什麼
快吃啊 獅子
但是要獅子啊 氣死啦
古有那個什麼 八點檔暴舉
現在要指著獅子啊
真的啦
錢都在專門銀行上
哲哲借我錢
每個人都要跟我借來不及
我心想記者說哲哲你要捐救護車
我心想說我還剛賺一千萬
你叫我捐五百萬
笑笑的說有打算六萬點在捐
你們不要這樣子
不過我覺得不錯啦
比分析師出了比績效也要比捐贈
大家一起回歸社會好不好
很多哲哲捐救護車就可以怎麼樣
我一個邏輯啦至少我有捐
第二個邏輯啦
你們至少可以一再證明說
我哲哲不用
跑多肉臉
明天被你罵嗎
我還是願意做這些事情啊
欸我不太一樣喔
我不是要講明星
明星我不跑多肉臉
他可能就沒辦法了
我不跑多肉臉
我可能賺更多喔
這是事實啊
我本金也夠啊
我可以不用管主管機關
都有限制
我就是官民政大了買股票啊
買到你嚇死你啊
一個期貨轉折
就一個賺七幾萬的
我槓桿稍微大一點
我又是不行
啊哲哲槓大啊
你叫我不要槓桿
我可不可以簡單一點
假設我有3億的資金
假設啦
我就一用槓桿啊
是不是
還有2億啊
而且一做槓桿我就敢拚啊
那隨便就可以賺大錢了
唉 我快氣死了
國安基金找你操盤
不要 不要 不要 不要
謝謝大家
All in了 他要All in了
4000多票
我還有錢
所以這個大數法則有無三%啦
唉呀 我真的快氣死了
來來
你們現在有錢了
來 拜託拜託 找一下
好不好
你們趕快買國票
或參加我反彈99專案
好不好
好不好 OK嗎
反彈就好 趕快來找我
因為什麼 因為你現在買
我跟你講講 我講什麼東西啊
我印象中沒錯的話
548萬中美金
那時候我第一次買的是
100多元
後來200元左右的時候我好像再加碼一次我已經忘記這個時間了 不好意思我只有200元我就可以買了結果還可以跌到157換句話說今天中美金如果禮拜一就算禮拜一暫停
我最好不要暫停
禮拜一暫停的話頂多170元
在這邊
你懂不懂
是
在這邊
在這邊你知道嗎
那離我的成本這邊
大概210220這邊
還有一段距離
200到220
聽得懂嗎
懂
我也有100多的成本
可是你成本現在就很低
所以你現在一堆股票買的都比我低
當然我精彩
我印象中沒錯
我精彩都賺錢
應該都賺錢
應該
我記得那時候成本很低
買了200多元
應該
本來是通通賺錢
現在都變成一堆股票
有的有
有的就會有賺
新會員沒有賺
所以你不要再說
哲哲 哇哲哲
賺很多
會員賠
沒有 我有些就會員賺翻的
賺翻的 好不好
只是新委員不敢說啦好不好
真不好意思
只會努力 所以只會努力啦
好不好
承擔嘛 一起承擔
只是我運氣又好啦
每次一買台灣50
有誰敢講說跟著台灣50敢跟我對坐
都台出於眾了
好不好
新委員我也是與民同苦啦
好不好 與民共苦啦好不好
OK嗎
好 你們賺到錢不用捐救護車
我來捐就好了好不好
6萬點好不好
6萬點我就捐救護車
6萬點的話那1億就賺5000萬吧
差不多吧
今天就賺1000萬了好不好
好快喔
一天一千萬
你會算數學吧
應該會吧
0050一天
暫停版不就是一千萬嗎
是
今天9.10%嘛
不是一千萬嗎
而且不只喔
我成本好像是93.3%
今天93.5%
懂嗎
所以應該一千多萬啦
沒錯吧
偶然就算了
我沒有看對戰單啦
應該就至少一千萬啦
唉
早知如此的就算出
53%的耶
我是全台灣多佗家將軍啊
你們要53%
你們是對不起我嗎
對不起 自己
我送一張圖給你啦
剛好本來
在想要不要講這張圖
現在台灣股市是不是漲上去對不對
對
沒錯啊 一天又漲三千點嘛 對不對
是
其實這邊買是最怎麼樣
最漂亮的 是不是
你以為那時候台灣股市是可可可氣
可以割捨 可以丟棄的
對不對
不好意思
這邊嘛 你們以為是可可可氣
就做空嘛 空手嘛
今天談到四萬三的時候對不對
是怎麼樣
可惜
再過幾天談到4萬7
可憐
真的可憐
來
再談到5萬
可悲
我講是針對空手的人
現在是可惜喔
談上去是可憐喔
談到5萬
創新高是可悲
你不要讓自己可悲的事情發生
這是你的選擇
你的選擇
不要一直怪
怪政府也好
怪哪個政黨也好
我們好手好腳
你有看哲哲節目
你已經打算主力做多了
你就只跨最後那一步
可最後那一步
你沒有all in
用現金all in
然後分上以後
你不一定要來找哲哲
我很實在
可是你沒有all in
本身就是這種錯誤
你沒有all in
本身是這種錯誤
不要把錢放在銀行
不要把錢放在保險公司那麼多
真的都不需要
你看 今天10%去哪邊找到
我就說了
為什麼要買台灣50%
台積電要好 洪小儀要好
幾十萬個員工 幾百萬個員工
在幫你賺錢啊
睡覺你都在笑
為什麼睡覺在笑
因為他們還要加班啊
台積電員工20小時要上班啊
20小時治的嘛
懂不懂意思
哇 激動
以後不要記得
那個莉莉跟小孩記得不要失職啊
好 不要失職
好啦好啦
樊軒
還有樊軒看一下
現在幾分了
四張
是這樣嗎
6196帆軒
帆軒這個這個
這果標
你看喔
607對不對
大概都
這個帆軒還6848
大概480
他都打7
7折以上
帆軒我不想買的原因
是因為他根本沒跌
你知道嗎
不是他不好
是他沒跌
是
所以我跟你講就是
你現在有台積電的人
我反而覺得
記得這件事
你台積電你記得
你記得有台積電的人
你反而要怎麼樣
要走
為什麼
台積電到高點只有怎麼樣
不到差不多110元對不對 沒錯吧
到高點不到110元啊
我現在在這邊啊 到高點這邊啊
不到110元啊
是 我不到5%啊
是不是 當然可能台積電算先穿新高啊
機率不高啊 台積電穿新高
台灣股市還沒48000的話
會震盪 重點是 台積電先穿新高
對不起
我現在有形象你知道 我現在很多
新的男粉 女粉 我真的有點緊張
既其他又怕刷刷開
好不好 各位沒有啦
打擱一下不好意思
來
開玩笑的
台積電離高點5%
可是台灣股市還差了5000點
你懂不懂
所以台積電到48000一定會震盪一下
懂不懂
自己想就知道到48000一定會震盪一下
然後跟你開玩笑一下 每天3000點
現在是先V型反轉
確定底部成立了
確定底部成立不會再破底了
原則上不會再破底了
所以台灣股市突破48000
很難
馬上很難
好不好
會馬上難
也要一段時間
一段時間不是說
假設那多久
我已經跟你講今年了
我昨天也看一堆留言說
郭總敢說今年上5萬點
現在是發現可以了
好奇怪
一天差別而已
好
所以台灣股市創新高
一定因為高檔有
有高檔有很多壓力嘛
是
可是台積電已經快要創新高了
台積電跟台灣股市是一步一區啊
你懂不懂意思
這邊高檔這麼多
這麼多賣壓
是不是這邊都賣壓 4萬8000
所以你上去4萬8000一定有壓力
所以台積電上去
再上去一定有壓力
可是這個時候 可是國際有沒有壓力
國際沒有壓力啊
國際有壓力也是在800元以上 你懂不懂
沒錯吧 沒錯
而且最近很多大巫被套牢了
他們會把他勢必
發誓會把他努力撞回去
有沒有講錯啊
黃永金也是一樣啊
我現在三根也很正常啊
我先談到1,200為什麼不行
這邊都賣
我先談1,200以上才有真正賣壓
是不是
我855談到1,200
多少
350元
差不多就48
是不是
48左右啦
還沒到48
差不多差不多
我談到120048
而且沒有壓力
沒有壓力
所以很多股票
可是台積電呢
台積電在5%就有壓力了
所以你現在要把一些跌很少的股票
叫我凡宣
你叫我買凡宣幹什麼
不是凡宣不好
而是很多股票更低
你一定要懂我邏輯
這些邏輯你聽得懂
但是你有一點沒有懂
那你要參加合會員
好不好
你看我今天都沒什麼推什麼專案來
我推專案
但我沒有推得很用力
有什麼
我根本不缺業績
我沒差啦
好不好
隨便你怎麼說
只說我賺一千萬也好
或者會員很多也好
人在座天在看
你再記得一件事
只是沒必要拋頭多一點
哇 不論賺錢賠錢都被人家罵
為什麼
因為我珍惜給你們生活
看一次少一次
有些人在網路上都罵我
講一些很奇怪的留言
你幫我回一下
好不好 OK嗎
我已經講了
我出一億的懸賞
兩億也可以
一億給你
一億給那個
永鋒中心 板心的營業員也好
或鑑山高層也好
你有任何證據說我那天沒下
你真的看永豐版新9A 9J
郭卓卓沒下 我用我名字下
郭卓卓沒有下
給你1億
再給那個營業員或券商
經理人1億
台幣
我說話說話
OK嗎
好不好
先跟大家講
所以不要說說我作假啦
我承受很大的壓力
就希望你開心而已
最後也大家很開心好不好
這是跟大家講的
來來來
所以來來來買太少了
夜盤超強賺快
夜盤現在很強
我們看一下
真的假的 瞇一下
夜盤現在還賺140
夜盤賺很多人
因為你知道
43,867
大家二翻天了
為什麼
正價差700點
又回到我熟悉的台灣股市
是
回來了
對對對
其實我跟你講
正二相有個問題
改天跟你講
以前台灣股市講錯了
之前前一點也講錯了
台灣股市以前是逆價差
所以逆價差最後會跟上點數嘛
比如說我逆價差500點
比如說我台灣股市現在4萬
期貨39000
那最後是不是結算的時候會
那1000點會拉上去
是
可是現在撞不到
現在正價差
相對反而虧
OK嗎
這跟大家講
所以你先看等一下怎樣分析室
好不好
台股還會跌到4萬點以下嗎
我今天畫面跑太快了
等一下
我今天畫面跑太快
你們問題我都滿意回答
今天實在很多鐵粉
不太會了
這種展法不太會
這種展法還能破4萬
那會跌很恐怖喔
可是我跟我說你不要緊張
機率很低
我認為機率不到3%
甚至不到1%
好不好
很低
只有投資長看我國劇
展天前
每個人都看外
有沒有看到
我都覺得
我多有人在傳的
是不是姚子姬母看我的節目
沒有關係
很多人看我的節目很正常
直播就1萬多
1萬2千人
136萬
怎麼可能沒聽過我郭哲龍
我當分析師20年
全台灣只有一位百萬粉絲
百萬粉絲的分析師就我
所以沒有關係
就是我給你們信心很好
我愛你們
每一位
金金金的你好
你們也好
I stay do
I love you
我愛你
記得真的愛你們
好不好
OK
男生也是一樣
女生一樣
好不好OK嗎
都愛你們
只要你們喜歡我
我都喜歡你們
好不好OK嗎
去想想看你要怎樣分析師
好不好
我們再最後看股票
有沒有股票
支撐大家
我會支撐大家的好不好
最後我再送大家一句話了
這句話啦
悲觀的人邏輯正確
樂觀的人賺走一切
這我今天講給大家很多話對不對
很多股票今天都漲停了
南亞科今天漲停了
南亞科今天漲停
跟我之前出的價格差不多啦
群年也是一樣
群年莫名其妙
我去群年2000元以下都可以買
你看群年更是一樣
所以我跟大家講
一堆股票會彈很兇
還會彈很快
你現在買
我真的沒辦法相信
100多萬粉絲裡面有70幾萬
好啦 我就算我們每一集大概
我們現在每一集大概看超過30萬人
等於30萬人裡面有15萬人還有錢
我們為什麼不跟著我買39000台股
沒關係 你們現在可以買更加的點位
確定底部的點位
所以趕快來參加我行李好不好
反彈99專案 很多股票
你就算今天暫停追
禮拜一追 你買的價格還是比我低
反彈99專案 參加就對了
又優惠又實在
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我們最後還是好好翻
算了開玩笑啦
歡迎來電洽群 0800668085
我叫LINE私信我
我只有這個LINE啊
我錄上來那邊淬一堆假的好不好
只有YouTube會少這些啊
臉書不少的啊
不少那些詐騙的啦
不太少啦
這LINE是實在的
上面寫官方認證的
你知道嗎好不好寫以認證的
後來電洽群 0800668085
記者拜託不要打電話
這是我們陸會專線
助理人員
研究人員很困擾好不好
OK嗎
0866 8085是入會專線
好多記者今天打電話
不是來入會
是來詢問我什麼時候有空
這不重點啦
歡迎大家請 08066 8085
或者加油來
失信我
反彈就專案
很多股票
動不動會攢一倍
攢60% 80%
你趕快參加阿列
不然你就會後悔一輩子
我愛你們
拜拜
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家